cependant près de 40 ans vous n'aviez
pas parlé de ce passé un peu plus ça
peut voir ça je sais pas non non mais
moi je voulais pas en parler quand j'ai
appris que la guerre était finie la
première chose que j'ai pensé
Ginette tu raconteras pas ton histoire
t'embêtera pas les gens à raconter ce
que tu as vécu parce que je ne voulais
pas embêter les gens à entendre toujours
avec l'histoire
quel message aujourd'hui vous souhaitez
faire passer
l'autre comme il est avec ses qualités
avec ses défauts avec sa couleur de peau
avec sa religion pourquoi que je vous
empêcherai de vivre vous n'êtes pas
juifs vous êtes noir alors vous êtes bon
à rien pas juive et noir
ben non vous êtes un être humain